How many of you honestly,
when you're thinkingabout
doing something vulnerable or
saying something vulnerable think,
"God, vulnerability is weakness.
This is weakness"
How many of youthink of vulnerability
and weakness synonymously?
The majority of people.
And that myth is
profoundly dangerous.
I define vulnerability as
emotional risk, exposure,
uncertainty.
Itfuels our daily lives.
And I've come to the belief -- this is
my 12th year doing this research
-- that vulnerability is our most accurate
measurement of courage --
to be vulnerable, tolet ourselves
be seen, to be honest.
If we're going to find our
way back to each other,
vulnerability is going to be that path.